there has been at least one explosion
outside kabul airport and reports of
gunfire u.s officials say it appears to
be a suicide attack unconfirmed reports
say there are several people dead and
injured
thousands of afghans and foreign
nationals have been gathering outside
the airport for days now desperate to
flee the country after the taliban
takeover the explosion comes after
western countries warned the area was a
target for a potential terror attack by
islamic state militants the united
states and allies have urged civilians
to leave the airport
let's thank you for the latest now to
kabul to journalist ali latifi ali
you're joining us on the line what more
have you learned about what happened
so i'm currently outside one of the
hospitals where the injured are being
transferred to
and we keep seeing ambulances and cars
drive by bringing injured in we've seen
children come in injured
it seems right now that it's really just
local residents directing traffic and
making sure that the injured can make it
into the hospital we don't really see
much of a taliban presence right now
one of their big police vehicles passed
by stopped to look and then kept going
um but right now it's still just people
scrambling to get the injured
into the hospital what kind of injuries
are you seeing
uh with the the problem is that they're
being uh crowded around so we can't see
exactly the injuries but
we we've seen uh you know people coming
in and we've seen cars being stopped and
saying you know we have injured we need
to get them in
and that's you know right now which is
just people coming in the hospital has
gurneys at the door
waiting for people
um because it's a long road from the
brad that side of the airport
because it's so crowded because that
much of that road is unpaved it's going
to take people a while to bring
the injured two different hospitals in
the city
although the amount of crowds
go ahead
also the amount of crowds will make it
very difficult you know if it has been
the last few days there are thousands of
people just lined up there
um and cars and it's a dirt mainly dirt
road so people coming there trying to
get into the city are going to change
face a lot of challenges especially with
sick and injured people in their
vehicles and have you been able to talk
to any of the people accompanying the
injured what are they telling you
uh they're just telling me that there
were you know possibly tens of thousands
near the gate where the explosion
happened and that you know after that it
just became
what usually happens after an explosion
where people run and are trying to you
know tend to the injured as quickly as
possible uh you know there were people
that were waiting for hours and hours
that day
um
that's yeah
and i mean obviously
this was a a a soft target though the
area outside the airport
right
right right and it's a big test of the
taliban you know because one of their
big sort of how they tried to sell
themselves was well if we join the
government or if we take over the
government then security won't be an
issue anymore and now we are seeing that
obviously security is an issue they
weren't even though the warnings were
out there they weren't and they were the
ones them and the cia backed
intelligence forces were the ones out
on the streets they weren't able to stop
this from happening either
so what does it signal uh ali
it's a good question because now we're
going to see the total capabilities to
address a situation like this as i said
right now i'm watching people on the
street who are probably just shop owners
and local residents directing the
traffic and ambulances coming this way
right now and they're trying to direct
the traffic to get it to come to the
entrance of the hospital as quickly as
possible
now i mean obviously this is early days
and and the situation is is very chaotic
but who would want to attack
afghan civilians
the so-called islamic state is is is a
good
guess because they are enemies of the
taliban and this again will make the
taliban look bad you know it will say
look you took over and you couldn't
provide security to your people
but at the same time of course this was
the u.s president's biggest concern
it's also another blow for the u.s and
the coalition isn't it
yeah oh completely completely because
this evacuation
has been you know a disaster from the
start
and
this is just you know
another part of that you know because
people were promised all of these visas
from germany and the uk and france and
the us and all of these other places
they thought you know unfortunately a
lot of people thought if i show up at
the airport maybe there'll be a chance
but i could get on a plane and go
somewhere
yes a life and death situation for
afghans at the airport ali latifi
reporting on those breaking developments
out of kabul thank you for now ali
appreciate it
and for viewers just joining us right
now we are covering breaking news at
this hour an apparent suicide blast has
rocked kabul's international airport
smoke has been visible over the airport
gate you can see it here
where several people were reported
killed
and it's where thousands had been
waiting in hopes of escaping afghanistan
and several of western officials had
warned of an imminent terror attack
all right let's take you now to
journalist
marty in kabul
have you learned have there been more
details that you learned about
there have been at least two explosions
apparently uh in this
ditch right next to the road one close
to abigail the gate where most afghans
tried to get in uh one close to a hotel
frequented by foreigners which was like
heavily secured um there have been
several casualties uh including at least
three wounded u.s soldiers um there
might be
more suicide bombers
in the area or have been
um
and
yeah that that is the the latest there
have been reports about shots being
fired but it was not clear in how far
this was like a firefight with attackers
or might have been just like warning
shots or soldiers uh reacting to um
perceived threats
was it a sizable explosion do we know
that and there's also reports of a
second explosion
uh what i have there was a second
explosion according to my information uh
what i have is that uh it is um
at least 30 people uh like uh
wounded and killed um so uh this this is
like about the size but details are uh
still like unclear it seems to be that
like attackers on foot brought
explosives so we're talking um about uh
at best like a few kilograms but like
not not a car bomb according to my
information but this is all
uh still uh
hard to verify
in terms of the taliban are are they in
control now i mean will the area be
evacuated what do we know about that
uh people fled from the scene obviously
um there have been taliban checkpoints
nearby
uh the the what the status of the scene
right now is is hard to say but honestly
it has also to be expected that at least
some afghans try to go back as soon as
possible to the gate fearing uh that
they uh that they otherwise can't get in
anymore um but yeah it's chaotic scenes
uh and it's it's not exactly clear how
it looks right now there
do we know if planes are still taking
off at this stage
planes have been taking off like right
when the explosion happened as far as i
was informed i myself am
quite a distance away from the airport
uh can't
hear or see anything at the moment but
it is likely that planes will still take
off because i mean the evacuation has to
be like wrapped up and it was anyway
like planned to to like uh to uh get
some of the refugees out here in the
next days and then the law stays to the
deadline uh to to get the soldiers out
uh that are now securing the airfield
of course the interesting uh uh well the
striking thing about this is of course
that this was anticipated i mean the in
the days leading up to this officials
have been warning people of the
possibility that a terror attack is
imminent so these warnings were not
heated
what has to be taken account here is
scenes were chaotic
um thousands of people it's impossible
to control everyone it was already
before the taliban took over campbell
like completely preventing suicides
attacks like this
would only be possible in a complete
police state where no movement is
allowed as long as there is some amount
of free movement there's like no way
that that
there can be like absolute security um
there have been reports but with these
chaotic scenes uh it was like really
extremely difficult uh to to track
people and uh to provide security in the
area
and in terms of as a target i mean this
is probably the softest target there is
in kabul right now
no not really i mean you could like set
off a bomb somewhere in the city where
uh checkpoints barely check vehicles uh
but you don't have a crowd um so for
for headline grabbing the kabul airport
was the best target uh but like softer
targets would be all around the city
just not same impact
so who would want to do this who would
who would want to
attack civilians and and you know make
the news this way
all signs point
declared islamic state there's no other
group that that uh would be able and
have the motivation to do that yesterday
a contact with
uh with contacts in the self-declared
islamic state told me that they intend
to attack the people at the airport
because they're deemed american spies
and collaborators so in their eyes
they're not civilians
when i checked lost a few minutes ago on
like social media channels of the
self-declared islamic state there has
been no
claim of responsibility but it is
expected that this will come
in our remaining moments together are
they competing for power
yes of course i mean the the
self-declared islamic state wants to
like get back uh
take territory um but now they're like
uh limited to underground networks so
they have the capability to stage such
attacks but they are a fringe group so i
mean we're not talking that they uh that
they are a real threat to the taliban
right now they have the aspiration to
contest them that's for sure uh but the
capabilities is lost uh largely limited
to to such uh asymmetric attacks right
asymmetric attacks franz marti reporting
from kabul on those breaking
developments thank you very much